I canada until the mattress one kill
lucky tatum this my boy Donald Trump you
got a mask on so you can't really see
him right now but that's okay um where
we gotta get worried gotta go oh he's
over here he's over here I'm gonna go
Finch and I'm going south okay baby okay
Jesus guys the best instagram ever to
follow is a character known as chihuahua
underscore Khloe one like the numerical
one okay that's all I gotta say okay
where we gotta go we gotta go we gotta
go this way baby yeah yeah yeah mm okay
um [ __ ] going on over there yeah my
[ __ ] hazmat suit on I don't know be
[ __ ] swimming it's okay
this is not my battle so I'm just rotted
there this okay let's say let's see yeah
they are they yes yes yes yes just where
I is told they'd break I [ __ ] i get in
here I don't [ __ ] know I got it no I
know it has any idea yep gotta get yeah
that doesn't hurt too much dude oh [ __ ]
huh oh this [ __ ] ok this come [ __ ]
suck is a good guy
I'm just like I'm a [ __ ] health care
mo oh sorry oh this [ __ ] very violent
but that's okay
who is shooting at me
like really running out of ammo what the
[ __ ] is up okay okay okay that that
happened guys that happened
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it oh Jesus Nick I
almost blew your [ __ ] brains out how
does anyone know that I [ __ ] get in
here
what the [ __ ] is that ok I [ __ ] rest
oh it's on
it's called shooting straight
okay okay we got the skull well
well what has gone on here why are they
heck I am a hand for a job okay I'm not
here up dance around ok ok here is
anyone here yes with this guy yeah again
again again
chase s no Oh get him right there
okay oh my god yeah he said what the
[ __ ] is that
let's get the [ __ ] out of here you know
cuz this is just a [ __ ] yay but babe
but yeah this is just a [ __ ] bay
yeah yeah yeah okay I got nothing like
20 years alone now so ya ready get ready
oh jeez I need a pizza I do a hot pocket
and how baby i need some some grace I
don't even you bake and I channel bacon
grease on the cup let me nice it's my
tongue in it let it swirl around in
there you know
okay get get get let's go let's go oh it
hurt hello IA Hey Ya Ya tender matches
fun come play